this was crude and poorly done so it's
probably I don't know I'd assume more
was a false flag yeah first I heard
there were two drones and that they were
brought down by Russian uh like
countermeasures and so that was the
Drone actually coming down as a result
of the Russian interference so that but
but I don't know if that was true or not
either I mean they released the
statement saying it was two unmanned
aerial uh two drones apparatuses and
they also said you know we have uh May
9th it's our Victory Day we we celebrate
the end or when Germany fell to the
Soviet Union and so this is lining up on
sort of to be an attack on our our
national pride basically this is this is
basically the White House it's like the
Russian version of The White House
Washington Post says it's the working
residence of Vladimir Putin but to fly a
drone I mean the explosion was very
small compared to the building just to
aim a thing into the top of the Kremlin
I don't see how that would get put maybe
they knew where they were headed and
they were trying to go right into his
office